il ya beaucoup d'industries qui
ressentent de la pression concernant la
diminution des émissions des gaz à effet
de serre avec toutes les manifestations
auxquelles on assiste la mobilisation
chez les jeunes et vous l'avez compris
avec ces images-là l'industrie des jeux
vidéo qui est l'une des activités les
plus populaires chez les 35 ans et moins
mais aussi l'une des plus polluantes et
cette semaine y des géantes de cette
industrie là qui ont présenté des
mesures pour diminuer leur empreinte
carbone on en parle avec renault
manuguerra gagner alors nos calories
donc on pense pas nécessairement aux
jeux vidéo quand on parle de pollution
n'ont effectivement pas c'est là qu'on
voit la différence qui peut avoir des
actions que le citoyen moyen pour faire
pour diminuer ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que les actions que des
grosses compagnies ou le gouvernement
peuvent faire parce que on a beau
vouloir que la personne a plus
écoresponsable la planète
il ya beaucoup d'activités qu'on fait
qui viennent avec des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre cacher qu'on n'est pas au
courant qu'on utilise le produit et les
jeux vidéo c'est un très bon exemple de
ça c'est des produits comme beaucoup
d'appareils électroniques qui viennent
avec beaucoup d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre cacher autant pendant leur
construction que quand ils utilisent non
on n'y pense pas tout de suite et c'est
pour ça que justement les plus grandes
compagnies des jeux vidéos de jeux vidéo
de la planète donc ce sont ont émis un
message cette semaine en marge du
mouvement d'action pour le climat
c'est une preuve qu'ils ont fait une
promesse qu'ils ont appelée on joue pour
la planète c'est une promesse de rendre
le milieu du jeu vidéo plus éco
responsable donc on a eu beaucoup
d'annoncés pendant c'est à ce moment là
la compagnie microsoft par exemple dit
qu'elle diminuait qu'elle diminuerait de
30% les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre tout le long de la chaîne de
production de ses consoles et luxin
company s est vu que sa dernière xbox a
été vendu à 80 millions d'exemplaires
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait avoir
un effet intéressant et un truc dont on
a beaucoup parlé c'est la compagnie sony
la preuve les propriétaires de la
playstation ont annoncé que la
playstation 5 leur prochaine console qui
devrait sortir au cours des prochaines
années avait dépensé 20 fois moins
d'électricité en mode veille
donc ça c'est quand aucun compartiment
aux consoles playstation 4 actuel ce
séjour disent que si un million
d'utilisateurs qui activent cette option
là ça pourrait sauver assez
d'électricité pour alimenter 1000
maison ça peut paraître peu mais la
maison mais quand on sait que 100
millions de consoles playstation 4 ont
été vendus partout dans le monde
ça commence à faire beaucoup
d'électricité est ce important dans des
pays où les pays produisent encore leur
électricité avec des centrales
thermiques qui émettent beaucoup de gaz
ait fait ça peut faire une différence
certainement on parle de quel genre
d'empreinte carbone présentement pour
les jeux vidéo il ya deux de grandes
catégories sont peu dire d'abord
l'électricité qu'ils consomment ce qui
est assez énorme il ya plusieurs études
qui ont été faits là dessus mais une des
plus intéressantes set et fait taire des
chercheurs du mighty qui ont montré
qu'ils aient eu se sont intéressés
jusqu'au joueur d'ordinateurs qui
sont-ils qui sont parmi les scellés
livres et qu'on soit les plus
énergivores sont peu dire et ont montré
que tous les joueurs d'ordinateur sur
terre consomme 75 milliards de
kilowattheures d'électricité à chaque
année ceci représente environ 25
centrales électriques donc dans le monde
en ce moment il ya 25 centrales
électriques tout leur électricité
c'est uniquement pour les joueurs de
jeux sur des autres si oui assure la
planète c'est énorme la consommation
d'électricité 790 vraiment beaucoup que
d'autres études qui ont été un peu plus
ciblées ils ont remarqué par exemple
auquel ils ont vraiment rien remarqué en
californie les jeux vidéo ça va présente
la cinquième consommation d'électricité
dans une maison donc si ça se fait dans
des endroits où l'électricité produit à
l'énergie thermique
ça va y mettre 12 millions de tonnes de
co2 par année soit c'est l'équivalent de
1.3 million de voitures sur les autres
tout en étant à la maison en jouant des
jeux vidéo puis si on regarde juste là
qu'on la construction ensuite delà de la
console s à une empreinte carbone énorme
aussi parce que c'est des métaux et
plein de métaux rares qui rentre dans la
construction des batteries des pièces et
tous ceux qui doivent être transportés
et puis même la console elle même
c'est un cycle de vie de 5 en moyenne
une console de jeux vidéo
à chacun sa vie plus longtemps c'est sûr
mais la nouvelle génération arrive à
chaque cinq ans dont quand ça arrive
beaucoup de joueurs qui se débarrassent
de leurs anciennes consoles et qu'on
fait ça qu'on l'a recycle ou qu on la
jette c'est un mec quand même beaucoup
de gaz à effet de serre vraiment
beaucoup une modification à faire pour
en arriver à ce n'est des jeux vidéo
carboneutre
une espèce est effective et là en plus
de jouer à la maison il y en a beaucoup
qui jouent en ligne maintenant donc
j'imagine que ça aussi ça s'ajoute si
oui c'est ça parce que les cvo parce
qu'on n'a pas acheté un objet matériel
qu'on est chez soi qu'on joue en ligne
un jeu qu'on à télécharger sur notre
console qu'on amène nécessairement moins
de gaz à effet de serre parce que quand
je vois ces jeux la notice pas notre
console qui fait le gros du travail à
l'oreille branchée sur un serveur ou
d'autres joies ou sur lequel d'autres
joueurs vont être connectés ses serveurs
le prête à des centaines de kilomètres
de chez nous peut-être même dans
d'autres pays qui l utilisent encore des
centrales thermiques pour émettre des
gaz à effet de serre donc jouer chez soi
même au québec où on utilise
hydroélectricité dans 20 ans on pourrait
être en train d'émettre des gaz à effet
de serre dans un autre pays et ça c'est
un problème d'internet dans son ensemble
que ça mais en partageant un des
courriers sur réseaux sociaux courriel
tout seul c'est ça utilise le même
système et des chercheurs qui ont
calculé que internet dans son ensemble
ça génère 300 millions de tonnes de co2
par année soit 6 1% des émissions
mondiales ce qui est quand même beaucoup
pour cette seule activité là c'est
énorme
est ce que pour revenir au jeu vidéo là
est ce que les engagements sont
suffisants ou ses premiers c'est un
premier pas mais les consoles de jeux
vidéo en général restent extrêmement
énergivore donc tous à souligner le
problème d'un production d'électricité
dont faut se tourner de plus en plus
vers des modes de production d'énergie
verte et c'est là que les actions
gouvernementales peut avoir un grand
rôle à jouer
donc tout ça c'est toute cette histoire
là des jeux vidéo ça montre comment les
actions citoyennes les actions de
compagnies les actions gouvernements
peuvent être on peut en faire un tout
pour diminuer nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais son essai de jouer
chacun dans sa cause sérieuse ça
marchera pas parce tout est connecté en
équipe comme il risquait d'y arriver
davantage merci beaucoup et l'on serait
intéressant merci